hello and welcome to this video playing
pay the bill it's usually a good idea
and by the way paying bills
I once a long time ago I close an
account on an online account that had at
a bank and a head um I didn't have a the
the balance of the account was not a
zero they it was some a couple of a
couple of euros and it was it was yeah
it was - yeah - a couple of euros and
first I don't know why and how exactly
but the bank sent me notices that I
should yeah that I should close that
account and pay the 301 zeros and for
some reason I never did it yeah I
somehow I got all those messages those
letters and at one point it seems that I
just tossed them I don't know what I did
but finally after quite a while they
they they made me pee every made me pay
a fee didn't make me pee they made me
pay a fee that was really substantial
and I really wished I would have paid
that earlier so pay your bills before
you have to pay all those ridiculous
fees at the issue anyway so what's going
on here and we call them a closed centre
position that looks a little bit like a
room therefore please
new Knight f4 I'm not super happy that I
play g3 now but I don't want not afford
to happen it's really move that you just
cannot allow I guess okay my mine idea
is unstable Seiko in Chico fi if I don't
think so and I can take and play 95
Bishop d2 is played to prepare before
you to control c5 sent the knight back
home
no it looks fine there is still no way
is going to play a 5 under good
circumstances just doesn't work I can
take play 95 and things flex falling
apart it's not working ok hmm that that
I should have considered a bit more
carefully that this is possible ok let's
immediately attack this construction hmm
there is still night see for threatening
to take and win material that's not too
nice
my position feels really loops here
somehow
I see you enter DM and now finally place
them
it's also night b2 here
if I go Bishop be one person I'd be too
and I have no square for the rook and I
can take me five but it doesn't help
and not happy I could stick with the
night here actually to put to still
prevent at 5:00 maybe yeah maybe that is
a good idea I mean again I wasn't happy
with my play but blacks queenside is
still not good young so Knight is
attacking g3 if I take it before as a
checked
okay I'm not happy about it and he's got
crazy 54 oh my goodness Quinn deform
it might have been a move it might have
been a move
Queen d4 is still interesting I'm not
sure that I can play Knight c4 really
why would you want to do that okay that
della didn't get I think that that
should help help my course quite
considerably
and it's really really out to play a
five year
[Music]
okay
so the the my main my main reason for
doing all this was to make it easier to
play I just wanted a little bit of
simplicity I'm really unsure about this
move wanted to get this closed and
introduce the idea with the peace
sacrifice this is the moment where you
can maybe do it but it doesn't quite
work unfortunately
yes played it well absolutely I mean
maybe he could have played better and
then post me problems real substantial
problems but he did a good job yeah I
never had anything is there any any way
to set up a problem maybe you blunders
g5 but does it look like it
the only minimal idea that I would have
is Knights e5 which looks fairly
ridiculous any idea result
how ridiculous is 95 probably a lot him
yeah there wasn't really I mean the
thing is maybe I was a little bit Chuck
I mean I was thinking I overlooked a
couple of things like around him I felt
like I maybe missed missed some things
and then I was maybe not ambitious
enough
this is threatening 93 and the CAPTCHA
on a fall you know this is what I want
to play but black can take and the
engine now gives this as leading to some
compensation it seems okay if he cannot
if this is actually good for me and the
engine indicates at least a slight
advantage then I should play this fi
forever yeah I mean after a five I can
only be worse but I didn't have Quinn
deform I was concerned about Queen
deform I have to do this and I've
thought there might be something because
that looks yeah it looks difficult for
example I didn't see it concretely but
the engine gives this and I was thinking
about stuff like that that somehow
unleashes have blacks mine a piece
activity computer says roughly equal
it's funny to this is this is this this
is supposed to be equal that's funny
but it doesn't seem like I'm lost on
anything but I have to enter those
complications so he went back I went to
age 2 and again quindi forward push
about 6 is actually is strong yeah it
was a good movie I think and now he took
instead of 24 24 here I was absolutely
concerned that Jenny would sacrifice the
Queen
I was thinking Luke shakes actually with
20 X is stronger because of this say now
I've got two hooks hanging and that
position is lost should be two was
really odd that immediately gives me an
okay position maybe I was playing too
conservatively now I know I'm not better
but I was just like let's trade some
stuff and get something simple to play
now queen g4 was winning now you had the
deal the problem is this is covered I
can actually make that move the problem
two blankets like here I'm threatening
to go to this Square and what do you do
against it you cannot prevent it running
I was a huge opportunity I was just
thinking okay let's play this ending and
try there but this just nothing it's
absolutely nothing as you're probably
not gorgey form as now we are really
just talking about a draw the computer
wants to pledge and or g5 yeah this is
in fact a good move to be honest I
should I should have thought about this
a little bit more also here should go g5
because the knight is in a position that
he can never attack him so this is a
little bit better than the game a little
bit is Silla draw but it's a bit better
than the game maybe I should have then
like here play g5 this is this is a
little bit more interesting
yeah it's to draw the engine gives some
advantage but it doesn't think I don't
think it does anything black is just
covering the b5 as the potential spot
where I could sacrifice and then nothing
happens now okay there were some chances
for both side but I think a reasonably a
well-played game thanks for watching
guys